alors on l'a constaté toute la journée
les mesures du gouvernement selon les
territoires ont fait couler beaucoup
d'encre avant leur mise en application
avec une situation sanitaire qui elle
continue de se dégrader
il en va en parler tout de suite avec
nos invités nous ont rejoints ce soir
pour partager leurs analyses
alexis poulain éditorialistes bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france avec nous également stéphane
ravier président du groupe rassemblement
national au conseil municipal de
marseille
merci à vous à vos côtés christophe
prudhomme porte parole de l'association
des médecins urgentistes de france
bonsoir on sera alors ses ventes
messieurs l'incompréhension à marseille
après l annonce de la fermeture totale
des bars et des restaurants
et c'est même la colère chez les
professionnels chez les habitants mais
aussi chez les politiques le président
de la région paca renaud muselier a
annoncé le dépôt demain d'un
référé-liberté en justice pour empêcher
la fermeture des bars et restaurants de
la métropole
aix marseille est-ce que vous saluer la
démarche stéphane ravier
je participerai demain au rassemblement
à l'appel des professionnels de la
restauration parce que effectivement
trop c'est trop
les les décisions aussi soudaine que
violente venus de paris et qui s'abat
sur marseille comme ça qui punit
marseille qui punit l'emploi qui punit
les restaurateurs parce que monsieur
verront manifestement s'affolent
monsieur vers ans qui préfère ouvrir le
non seulement le parapluie mais le
paratonnerre et le paa judiciaire il ne
veut pas se retrouver sans doute devant
les tribunaux avec son incompétence
au surlendemain de son incompétence et
de son et près de 100 m préparation
pardon lors de la première vague donc
aujourd'hui prend des mesures
coercitives violente sans en informer
sans dialoguer avec les élus de
marseille et sur l'ensemble de la
métropole parce qu'il y à 92 communes du
département qui sont touchés par ces par
ses décisions unilatérales et ça serait
le coup de grâce le coup de grâce pour
deux
nombreux restaurateurs on ne peut que
s'y opposer christophe prudhomme je
rappelle que vous êtes porte parole de
l'association des médecins urgentistes
de france il ya la guerre des chiffres
aussi qui enfin en ce qui concerne
marseille entre un gouvernement qui lui
pointe retour local d'incidence du coït
et puis des élus locaux qui assure que
l'équipe que l'épidémie commencé à
décroître
christophe prudhomme en tant que médecin
à ces mesures est ce qu'elles sont
indispensables aujourd'hui même si
l'épidémie commence à décroître
quel est votre regard sur cette
situation il ya clairement eu il ya
clairement une erreur politique
les mesures de santé publique ne sont
bonnes que quand elles sont acceptées
par la population
ce que vous avez de stratégie en terme
de santé publique soit la coercition
brutale c'est la méthode chinoise qui
est très efficace mais qui était
acceptable chez nous ou alors il faut
gagner la confiance de la population or
là le gouvernement ferait tout son
contraire et attise les contradictions
les mesures ne sont pas comprises elles
veulent
le gouvernement va les appliquer de
manière autoritaire donc c'est
complètement contre-productif en termes
de santé publique
par ailleurs vous savez le problème
aujourd'hui pour nous professionnels de
santé c'est pas un afflux de malades
c'est que le gouvernement n'a rien fait
pendant les quatre mois de répit que
nous a laissé l'épidémie pour augmenter
les lits dans les hôpitaux
donc aujourd'hui les hôpitaux ne sont
pas en capacité de gérer les patients
classiques qui ont rappelé les hôpitaux
parce qu'on les a laissés à l'abandon
pendant trois mois et nous avions déjà
un suffisamment de lits de réanimation
pour les prendre en charge
depuis des années mais non sont le
manque de lits de réanimation donc les
quelques dizaines de malades
supplémentaires qui arrive aujourd'hui
et qui ont besoin de lits de réanimation
et qui sont atteints de la comique 19 et
bien créé une situation de tension et de
crise mais qui était prévisible depuis
plusieurs mois nous disons ils font
réellement embaucher massivement dans
les hôpitaux pour ouvrir des lits et
l'élite père elle pas comme dit le
ministre de la santé des lices
saisonniers
voyez ouvrir des lits quand tu es malade
sont en attente on d'urgence eh bien
écoutez c'est une erreur politique parce
que moi ce que j'attends des politiques
gérer c'est prévoir et c'est pas prendre
des mesures en urgence et surtout de
prendre des mesures avec des virages à
180 degrés incompréhensible pour la
population et puis pour terminer vous
savez je viens d'avoir les chiffres
concernant marseille que m'a envoyé mes
collègues des hôpitaux de l'ap-hm alors
ils sont en baisse et pas qu'à écouter
ils sont stables pour l'instant ils sont
stables
c'est à dire que nous avons depuis
maintenant quelques semaines n'ont pas
une deuxième vague mais une arrivée de
patience allemand haute de 50 s'abaisse
quelques jours sa réelle demande
ce qui est clair c'est qu'il va falloir
apprendre à vivre avec l'épidémie et
avec un nombre de malades conséquent
atteindre lakovic 19 pendant les mois
qui viennent et pendant peut-être les
années qui viennent donc l'urgence
aujourd'hui l'urgence aujourd'hui c'est
un que les gens puissent se faire tester
par les résultats dans la journée pour
pouvoir s'isoler
parce que là c'est la curée la plus
totale depuis plusieurs mois et 2
il faut augmenter massivement les
capacités hospitalières en embauchant
massivement dans les hôpitaux
voilà ce sont les deux mesures
essentielles et toutes les querelles qui
existent aujourd'hui avec des mesures
qui sont incomprises par la population
et bien créé quoi des situations qui
vont être pire
il est pire que ce qu'on veut prévenir
fermer les bars et les restaurants mais
les gens vont se réunir chez eux sans
aucune protection
parce qu'on va pas envoyer les policiers
pour frapper à la porte et pour voir si
des gens sont à distance et puis quand
même à marseille à marseille qui est une
ville du sud à moi je suis plutôt dans
le nord
mais écoutez quand vous êtes sur une
terrasse les risques de contamination
quand vous êtes en milieu ouvert sont
très limités donc utilisons les
terrasses temps qu'ils font qui fait
beau évitons effectivement que les
restaurants et bien utiliser les espaces
intérieurs
ça ce sont des mesures intelligent mais
fermé brutalement les restaurants c'est
complètement contre-productif c'est
comme effectivement ne pas autoriser les
à faire un petit peu la fête tout en
respectant un certain nombre de règles
voilà interdire c'est provoquer des
réactions contre-productive en termes de
santé publique des turelles
effectivement et une passe d'armes
aujourd'hui via les réseaux sociaux
entre le président de la région paca
renaud muselier et le ministre de la
santé on regarde et je vous donne la
parole après l'exploit j'apprends avec
étonnement et colère une décision pour
laquelle la mairie de marseille n'a pas
été consultée rien dans la situation
sanitaire ne justifie cette annonce
je n'accepte pas que les marseillais
soient victimes de décisions politiques
que personne ne peut comprendre les
décisions annoncées ce soir dont je
mesure la portée pour les marseillais
vise précisément à la protéger alors que
tous les indicateurs sanitaires sont
très dégradées ce dont je me suis
entretenu cette après midi avec votre
premier adjoint et le président renaud
muselier
un coup de téléphone n'est pas une
concertation olivier ferrand quand
l'appel est passé à 18h30 pour une
intervention à 19h dans la précipitation
cette décision est unilatérale inadaptée
et injuste
vous pensez être courageux en fait vous
perdez votre sang froid
alexis poulain qu'est ce que vous
observez dans cette passe d'armes
c'est une perte de sang froid du
gouvernement comme le souligne renaud
muselier
c'est surtout la même un préparation la
même unité dans la gestion de cette
crise sanitaire depuis mars
rien n'a été fait rien a été appris les
lits qui aurait dû être pérennisé ouvert
les médecins qui auraient dû être
embauchés les soignants qui aurait dû
être embauchés tout ça n'a pas existé
la rentrée qui aurait dû être préparés
dans le discours d'olivier ferrand il
hier il n'y avait aucune mention des
écoles des universités qui ont été seuls
à gérer l'afflux massif d'écoliers et
d'étudiants dans des lieux où bien sûr
la s'échanger à nouveau le virus
l'impréparation de ce gouvernement elle
est inédite
elle est incroyable et il voudrait que
ce soit la faute des français ils
voudraient que la culpabilité de cette
crise sanitaire soit entièrement sur le
dos des français qui sont trop bêtes
pour comprendre qu'ils sont trop
indisciplinés pour mettre leurs masques
qui font n'importe quoi c'est faux les
français je trouve ils sont extrêmement
patients ils sont extrêmement calme avec
ce gouvernement qui tient je ne sais pas
comment parce que là on a affaire à une
gestion politique de la crise qui n'a
rien à voir avec d'effets sanitaires
moi j'aimerais savoir quand on parle de
réanimation en réalité combien de
personnes sont intubés aujourd'hui
qu'est ce que c'est que ces chiffres on
n'a pas les chiffres que vous avez
vendredi des chiffres qui arrive on a
300 morts qui disparaissent le lendemain
parce que finalement il ya une erreur de
comptage qu'elle quel crédit peut-on
donner aux chiffres remontés par les rs
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'il se passe
dans les systèmes d'urgence je sais que
les médecins se font leur travail mais
que fait le gouvernement pour les aider
rappelez-vous la première vague les
médecins demandait des masques de la
prod et des outils de protection des
moyens on les applaudit c'est tous les
soirs à la fenêtre
les moyens sont arrivés beaucoup trop
tard il ya eu des morts au sein des du
personnel soignant ne l'oublions pas il
les maux de l'hiver ans qui disait que
le masque est inutile à l'époque il y à
toute la chaîne des tests aujourd'hui
qui ne fonctionne pas parce que on
manque de lakic parce qu'on n'a pas su
organiser cette chaîne de test alors je
veux bien qu'on est maintenant monsieur
bayrou à la planification de la relance
mais j'aurais peut-être une
planification de la gestion sanitaire
aujourd'hui c'est du grand n'importe
quoi une improvisation permanente de la
part du gouvernement qui veut se
défausser de ses responsabilités sur les
responsables politiques à l'échelon
territorial régional local municipal
cela se rebellent ils ont raison et je
les trouve encore gentil dans leur
rébellion parce que renaud muselier a
raison d'essayer de tout faire pour
arrêter ce délire politique parce que ce
n'est pas du tout scientifique bien sûr
que les restaurants n'ont pas être
montrés du doigt ils ont mis en place
des mesures d'accueil
iliad était il ya des terrasses et des
espaces ouverts également ses les lieux
de convivialité
pourquoi le virus ne serait dangereux
que dans les lieux de convivialité les
rassemblements familiaux alors que dans
les univers c'était bondé on n'en parle
pas olivier derand c'est bien là l'objet
de ne pas en parler volontairement dont
donc cette gestion politique elle est
lamentable
il faut le dire et je trouve que
l'opposition politique reste bien en
deçà de ce qu'elle pourrait faire parce
que là on rentre dans quelque chose qui
est du domaine pour moi du virtuel de la
science fiction
or la science existe ce virus et bien il
a un taux de létalité qui est certes
sévère mais qui n'ont même pas non plus
quelque chose qui demande à a sans arrêt
demandez aux gens de rester chez eux
confinés comme comme on est en train
petit à petit de remettre des petits
cailloux
parce que si ça continue comme ça bien
vous pouvez oublier noël et le jour de
l'an à la fin de l'année et et aucune
mesure en face pour réellement aider
ceux qui en ont besoin
les soignants les gens qui accueillent
du public que ce soit dans les écoles ou
ailleurs et les restaurateurs alors on
va encore bruno le maire l'a dit faire
des mesures économiques pour aider les
restaurateurs mais les restaurateurs ils
veulent pas d aide ils veulent faire
leur travail tout simplement continuer
de servir les gens et des lieux de
convivialité
parce que ça suffit de vouloir à tout
prix enfermer les gens chez eux et ne
les fait ressortir que pour travailler
dans des transports bondé et ensuite
dans des bureaux où là encore le virus
peut circuler sans aucun problème donc
on demande de la clarté et on demande
aussi de la responsabilité de la part
des dirigeants politiques qui
aujourd'hui à paris et bien semble tout
faire pour vouloir éviter la
responsabilité christophe prudhomme
alexis paula s'est interrogé justement
sur ces chiffres est ce que vous savez
précisément vous avez des informations
sur ces chiffres
combien de personnes sont intubés est-ce
que c'est très clair et précis oui nous
avons des chiffres mais vous savez la
question c'est l'évolution d'antan les
chiffres quotidiens y compris comme le
disait votre éditorialistes qui ne sont
pas vérifiées donc on corrige enfin
voyez nous nous sommes assez irrité de
crs qui le demande qui nous harcèle
quotidiennement pour avoir des chiffres
pour remplir les tableaux excel et je
voudrais insister sur une chose c'est
que alors que la belgique est un des
pays les plus touchés au monde beaucoup
plus que nous rapporter à la population
la première ministre belge ce matin a
dit clairement il vaut mieux des mesures
simples allégé qui sont acceptées par la
population plutôt que les mesures
contraignantes qui vont être contestées
voilà il faut que le gouvernement
comprenne qu'il a perdu la confiance de
la population des soignants et donc
cette perte de confiance en son discours
inaudible et moi j'insiste
j'insiste sur le fait qu' aujourd'hui
effectivement il y à une reprise de
l'épidémie avec un nombre de malades qui
nationalement augmente lentement mais si
nous sommes en crise c'est parce que
nous n'avons pas armer nos hôpitaux
je rappelle que nous sommes revenus à un
nombre de lits en réanimation que l'on
considérait déjà comme insuffisants au
mois de février pour pouvoir encaisser
le pic que l'on a connu nous sommes
revenus à ses 5500 lit dans mon
département qu'il ya des départements
les plus touchés que la
seine-saint-denis
nous avons un nombre de lits aujourd'hui
ouvert qui est inférieur à celui que
nous avions l'an dernier parce qu'il n'y
a pas assez de personnel nous voulions
ouvrir une unité de 25 lits le directeur
hier en réunion nous a dit je n'arrive
pas à embaucher des infirmières voilà
c'est ça la réalité
donc il ya une véritable colère
aujourd'hui chez les soignants
parce que ce discours du gouvernement
est contre productif et il s'occupe pas
des priorités que nous
on cible et déjà depuis plusieurs mois
et surtout quand on le dit qu'il n'a pas
d'argent pour l'hôpital mais écoutez
nous avons dépensé là je pense quasiment
un milliard et demi d'euros pour les
tests tests qui l'ont servi quasiment à
rien parce que quand vous tester les
gens et plus résultat à rennes 8 à 10
jours après ça ne sert à rien donc les
foules et surtout dernier élément qui
m'a particulièrement c'est l' annonce
par le premier ministre lors de son
intervention il ya une huitaine de jours
qu'il allait embaucher deux mille
personnes dans les ars et à l'assurance
maladie c'est-à-dire des contrôleurs
voilà qui on embauche des contrôleurs
alors qu'on a besoin de soignants sur le
terrain pas des contrôleurs voilà donc
tout ça montre bien que il faudrait pour
une fois réellement écouté la population
leurs élus et les professionnels
voilà si on veut pouvoir avancer parce
que ce virus va être là pendant
plusieurs mois peut-être pendant
plusieurs années
il faut bien qu'on vive au quotidien
faut apprendre à des maux quotidiens et
pour rassurer quand même la population
oui il ya un an de tests positifs
importants
le nombre de patients hospitalisés
augmente depuis quelques semaines mais
écoutez le nom de mort reste
relativement limitée regarder les
chiffres
ce qui est important c'est la mortalité
sa mortalité reste aujourd'hui une
relativement maîtrisé c'était fade rasé
nous avons augmenté
nous avons amélioré nos techniques de
réanimation on a du moins les patients
et on a des traitements qui sont pas des
traitements contre le virus mais contre
les complications qui améliore qui
diminue le temps des animations et qui a
fait baisser la mortalité qui était
initialement de 30 % en réanimation à
15% aujourd'hui voilà tu risques et
christophe lidon veille on va on va
s'interroger effectivement sur les
coudes des élus avec vous stéphane
ravier vous êtes aux premières loges à
marseille est ce que les élus
locaux ils ont été concertés ces
derniers jours cette fermeture des bars
des restaurants à ce qu'elle avait été
mis sur la table et moi hier soir encore
j'étais avec maires des bouches du rhône
et ses élus et alors que nous évoquions
la situation de sa commune il a il a
saisi son portable parce qu'il l'a senti
vibrer il a lu ce qui apparaît c'est ce
que la presse il lui faisait savoir et
bien à savoir que le préfet avait décidé
la fermeture des bars des brasseries à
partir à partir de samedi donc il m'a
regardé et m'a tendu le téléphone denis
voilà voilà maintenant il va falloir que
je me débrouille avec ça ils n'ont été
ni consultés ni même informé avoir avant
les autres ils ont appris qu'en tout à
chacun vient la presse c'est un
véritable véritable preuve de mépris
mais je dirais que le préfet lui-même
finalement a lui aussi été pris de court
parce que avant d'être parmi vous là
messieurs ce soir il y à quelques
minutes encore j'étais en mode audio
conférence avec des parlementaires et
avec le préfet de région justement qui
nous apprenait que ce soit à l'heure où
nous parlons
eh bien il n'a toujours pas délimiter la
zone des communes qui seraient
concernées par ces fermetures
alors que le ministre verra on nous
disait hier évoqué hier la zone
métropolitaine c'est à dire les 92
villes qui constitue la métropole mais
montrer une carte des bouches du rhône
qui compte elle 119 communes ont même eu
hier la communication du ministre
étaient contradictoires en fait il
parlait de la métropole en montrant une
carte des bouches-du-rhône et
aujourd'hui encore son préfet le préfet
de région et bien n'a pas encore eu le
temps de
de délimiter la zone donc des des
communes qui seraient frappés par les
conséquences et vous le disiez messieurs
de l'affolement et de l'incompétence de
son gouvernement si bien incarnée par
monsieur verra voilà mon année donc les
élus évidemment noms n'ont pas été
informés ils sont vent debout et je
tenais à vous dire que j'entendais que
les élus étaient été patients ils le
sont de moins en moins et les
professionnels aujourd'hui à marseille
en particulier et j'imagine qu'avec sans
prendre en compte quand même l'honneur
eh bien ils sont désormais dans une
volonté je dirais donc découdre certains
ont annoncé qu'ils ne fermerait pas leur
établissement parce que fermer
l'établissement
en quinze jours après des mois de
difficultés ça serait tiré le rideau de
façon définitive donc il ne nous rend
pas sur ordre du poids du ministre de la
santé et sont décidés à engager un bras
de fer parce qu'il s'agit tout
simplement de sauver l'emploi de sauver
l'emploi de milliers et de milliers de
marseillais depuis qu rhodanien alexis
vous là on se souvient pourtant de la
volonté du gouvernement de s'appuyer sur
les territoires justement sur les
autorités sur les élus bien pour adapter
les mesures pendant cette crise
sanitaire
comment est ce que vous comprenez
finalement ce manque de dialogue
visiblement en tout cas d'après ce que
nous dit stéphane ravier entre le
gouvernement et les élus locaux et ce
manque de dialogue et il est
systématique avec ce gouvernement avec
la façon dont il gère les affaires du
pays
on fait semblant c'est le en même temps
c'est à dire qu'il ya des discours et
puis il ya des actes dans les discours
on est toujours pour la concertation
sociale quelle qu'elle soit le travail
avec les territoires ça c'est pour les
caméras ça c'est pour le discours et
faire croire que oui la raim rappelez
vous aimez le maquereau et est élu sur
le principe de bienveillance on a vu la
bienveillance à coup de deux lanceurs de
balles de défense et de grenades
lacrymogènes
donc tout le discours n'a rien à voir
avec les actes donc pour ce gouvernement
pour le juger il faut le juger sur les
actes et les actes ils parlent
d'eux-mêmes impréparation mensonges et
et non concertation
enfin cette idée d'appeler une
demi-heure avant les annonces de ne pas
prévenir les élus de ce qu'il va se
passer dans leur circonscription c'est
incroyable comment peut-on après avoir
un premier ministre qui se met en avant
en disant je suis le premier ministre
des territoires il va falloir
décentralisée non on a là une vision
jacobine comme on l'a toujours eue mais
pire encore avec ce mensonge des
territoires qui fait que derrière il ne
sert qu'à une chose se défausser de la
responsabilité sur les élus locaux et si
jamais ça se passe mal eh bien ce sera
vers les mers vers les responsables de
régions vers les élus de des territoires
qu'on va se retourner en disant mais
qu'est ce que vous avez fait pourtant
consignes du gouvernement était clair et
on n'a pas discuté ensemble ça suffit je
crois que les responsables auront des
comptes à rendre
je le redis encore ici aujourd'hui il ya
plusieurs procès plusieurs plaintes du
moins qui sont déjà déposées contre les
responsables politiques au niveau
gouvernemental
ceux là veulent tout faire pour ne pas
être responsable ils sont responsables
de la mauvaise gestion de la crise
sanitaire ils sont responsables avec ce
grand confinement de la crise économique
dans laquelle nous sommes
c'est pas les seuls bien sûr c'est au
niveau mondial mais faut voir le niveau
à laquelle se retrouvent l'économie
française est aujourd'hui donc que
l'idée de d'aider des gens qui l'ont mis
en finalement en difficulté je crois que
on a un conseil scientifique qui a donné
tous les conseils qu'il fallait on a des
professionnels de médecine qui savent
très bien comment faire et qui demande
des moyens ça veut dire quoi
des gens supplémentaire des lits
supplémentaires jamais cela n'ont été
entendus
pour ce qui est de l'éducation c'est
pareil les professeurs demandent de
dédoubler les classes davantage de
professeurs on a des soi-disant des
milliards qui vont venir de l'union
européenne avec ce plan de relance
plutôt que de l'utiliser à embaucher
finalement des personnels pour aider là
où c'est nécessaire dans les temps qui
viennent
et bien non on va aider les banques à ne
pas faire faillite on va aider les
grandes entreprises à faire des plans
sociaux
on va un peu donné aux tpe et pme qui
elles vont avoir beaucoup de mal
c'est elles qui font l'emploi en europe
et en france je le rappelle donc tout
est fait à l'envers par ces technocrates
parce qu'ils décident de paris parce
qu'ils se refusent à finalement écouté
et à reconnaître leurs erreurs
enfin c'était incroyable d'entendre à
nouveau si bête ndiaye hier devant la
commission denquête et pour dire que
abbaoui comme d'habitude c'est la faute
des français qui n'y comprennent rien
non les français en ont marre dedans
tendre ça en ont marre d'être pris pour
des idiots ils ne sont pas idiots et je
crois que ça va très mal se passer dans
les semaines et les mois qui viennent si
le gouvernement ne change pas de
stratégie par rapport à la gestion de
cette crise merci en tout cas tous les
trois d'avoir répondu à nos questions
n'a bien entendu à vos interrogations
votre incompréhension parfois votre
colère également merci à vous alexis
poulain je rappelle que vous êtes
éditorialistes merci stéphane ravier
président du groupe rassemblement
national au conseil municipal de
marseille et merci à vous et christophe
prudhomme porte parole de l'association
des médecins urgentistes de france